obviously the Persian Gulf War you know
well 1990-91 after the Saddam's invasion
of Kuwait and in the 1991 war it's
important for two reasons one is it
shows you know the United States trying
to use the the UN as they believed it
had been intended to design to be used
right with the UN Security Council being
the kind of forum through which we would
be policing the world where we and
others would be policing the world doing
so by kicking Saddam out of Kuwait yes
also understand the end of that war and
how that were ended because it was in
many ways it foreshadowed the future the
war ends in April of night or march in
1991 and there's a humanitarian crisis
in northern Iraq and US troops are sent
to northern Iraq and occupy the
territory of northern Iraq to try to
protect the Kurds and a whole host of UN
Security Council sanctions come into
play you know get passed at that time in
part of the wars and you know you know
on limiting Saddam's ability to govern
his own country and basically you know
on whose weapons programs huge sanctions
and also again US troops occupying
northern Iraq and in many ways that is
the moment in which our entanglement
with Iraq is sort of cemented and that
entanglement then last throughout the
1990s you know through 911 and we're
still entangled with a rock today so
it's important to kind of see that the
beginning of the Iraq story is not a
story that begins in 2003 with our
invasion of Iraq or 2002 and Bush
started to sort of beat the drums of war
the the opening date is August of 1990
the day that Saddam invades Kuwait and
the US decides to stand against that
invasion and get involved in solving
that problem and that's really the seeds
of what has borne out over the years i
think you mean part of part of the part
of the story moving forward it's a story
of campaigns because we're again it's
it's it's the intersection of politics
and policy and campaigns or where
they're about drawing distinctions you
know one side tries to distinguish
himself from the other so I think
understanding the campaigns as sort of
hinge points or windows into which
you can understand what was going on in
the Democrat and Republican sides on
foreign policy during these years is
quite important so of course the 92
campaign between clinton bush and ross
perot the 96 campaign between dole
clinton ross perot in the two thousand
campaign between gore bush and Ralph
Nader and sort of the windows that each
of those candidacies give us into
foreign policy during these years and
then the events I mean in the early
1990s the events that are mainly these
sort of so-called ethnic conflicts or
humanitarian crises that crept up on us
and really sort of dominated foreign
policy Rwanda Somalia Bosnia Haiti and
you know all of which are kind of have
our sort of negative in terms of the
history of American foreign policy you
know the sort of bad stories although
one of them becomes the important kind
of it's the it's it's an important
subject in which we we sort of come out
of our of our shell which is Bosnia and
that in Dayton we ended up in 1995 by
ending the Bosnia war by negotiating the
Dayton Peace Accords that was sort of a
turning point for America in the world
in that it was a first time Clinton and
really gained confidence in the use of
force and using American power with our
friends but also not being afraid to go
it alone to try to do something that he
thought was important and the success of
that I think only helped as we move
throughout the 90s give Democrats more
confidence when it came to using us
power in the world and then I would also
say in the early to mid 90s these trade
agreements Bill Clinton's efforts in 93
to pass the NAFTA agreement the next
year to pass the the category which
created the WTO these are these are you
know we're huge efforts by the clinton
ministration to make an important
statement about america's approach to
the global economy and also to try to
change the way we did things here at
home we're still dealing with the
legacies of that positive i think but
also politically largely negative in
some ways at least on the Democratic
side I think thinking more towards the
late 90s clearly 1998 operation desert
fox against a rock december of 1990
aight was the culmination of a struggle
over several years with Iraq over
weapons inspections and Saddam's
potential to develop weapons of mass
destruction I think we have a whole
chapter of sort of in our book that
details the the sort of the struggle the
Clinton had with Iraq throughout the
1990s leading up to 1998 and what is a
little sobering in retrospect is sort of
recounting the the statements that many
clinton officials made at the time about
you know sadhana the threat from Saddam
and the potential he had to develop and
weapons of mass destruction and you know
what America might have to do about that
and there was a sense very much a sense
that you know at the end of clinton's
term in iraq was a was a piece of
unfinished business and and we described
in the book where we're approaching at
this moment a third iraq hand off the
first hand off was between george HW
bush and Bill Clinton where you know we
were still engaged in Iraq in a serious
way and it was sort of an unsatisfying
hand off the second hand off occurred in
2001 with Bill Clinton to George W Bush
and Clinton told George W Bush during a
transition meeting that he regretted
that Saddam he still hadn't found a way
to deal with Saddam I mean invasion was
not on the table but he was frustrated
that this was a problem that he had to
hand over his successor and of course
this January we're approaching our third
Iraq and off it's a much more troubling
and problematic hand off because of the
fact we have some hundred hundred and
thirty thousand troops there lost these
lot so many lives and it's a much more
harmful one and I think our hope is just
recounting this history that the next
hand off you know hopefully it's eight
years when Barack Obama hands off to
somebody that it's there in Iraq is not